some breaking news now crawleytown and
their suspended manager john yems have
parted ways the league two club has
announced that in a statement mr yams is
facing multiple investigations into
claims made by seven players who accused
him of repeatedly using racist language
and segregating players let's get more
now from our correspondent sadia
chowdhury she's in the newsroom for us
this afternoon and sadia what have the
club been saying
well this is a decisive move by the club
to now part ways they say with john yams
as you say he has been accused of using
repeatedly using offensive and racist
language very serious allegations
including allegations that he segregated
changing rooms along racial lines so
non-white players had to use different
changing rooms to white players which
has been described by some anti-racist
campaigners as modern day apartheid
now we have this statement from crawley
town football club
that says that it has mutually agreed to
part ways with john yams effective
immediately um
i'll read out the statement it comes
from preston johnson the co-chairman of
crawley town fc he says we're looking
forward to the next era of crawley town
football club we have an opportunity to
build on more than 125 years of rich
history and take this club to the next
level we're eager to partner with our
players and supporters as we build a
team and community that red devils fans
can continue to be proud of both on and
off the pitch
and as i say these allegations were made
by multiple players seven players going
forward and off the back of those
allegations john yims was being
investigated by three separate bodies
the
professional footballers association
that's the pfa the fa and also
the club which is owned by american
owners and
the pfa which is investigating
this incident has also said it has
offered counseling to the players who
have been affected and who have raised
those complaints it's offering support
to them now we don't know from this
statement whether the crawley town fc
investigation has concluded and that's
why he's been sacked or whether he has
left before the conclusion of
that
investigation as for the club itself the
uh they are going to be managed in the
interim by um
their interim manager who is louis young
the uh
the england football ashley young's
brother they face uh older athletic in
their final game of the season their
12th in division two
okay sadia thank you very much